wir alle können nur spekulieren aber die
zusammenhänge denke ich sind sind wir
haben in wenigen wochen in russland
regionalwahlen 13 neue regionen bällen
auch der neue regionen wählen dann ein
gouverneur wie dort die wahlen ausgehen
sind für putins system wichtig die
zustimmungsraten zu ihm als präsident
aber auch zu seiner partei weil den
massiven den keller
wir haben seit 2014 wirtschaftliche
stagnation in russland also das ist
alles etwas was das system putin massiv
unter druck setzt und in dem rahmen der
situation glaube ich es gut ihn auch zu
viel im weg und dazu gehört auch das
töten von menschen